[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
weltmännertag
ich dachte balu attackiert mich
ich bin doppelt so groß wie tun hatten
diamant schwert
das wollen wir mal sehen wenn ich das
gleich in 100 programme aber egal da
fahren heute keine zeit denn meine
lieben freunde wir haben heute wieder
extrem viel zu tun bei lueg kommt direkt
mit und wir verlassen doch unser
stronghold hier vorne was wir in der
letzten episode erfolgreich gemeistert
haben bzw
egal
wo kommt ihr denn alle her
ich liebe schnee bekommen habe ich schon
häufiger gesagt generell mit shader und
so die ganzen bäumen und der schnee wie
ich schon sehr gerne lieben freunde
darum soll es heute allerdings nicht
gehen denn gerade bereits gesagt in der
letzten episode haben wir genügend zeit
in der festung verbracht und haben eine
menge sachen auch dort gefunden nicht
nur ärzte und eine menge bücher sondern
auch verzauberte bücher und da habt ihr
mir fleißig in die kommentare
geschrieben was ich auf welchen
gegenstand hut zaubern soll da wird
beispielsweise geschrieben ein schmucker
du musst unbedingt unendlichkeit und
flamme auf deinen wohnung packen denn
dann brauchst du nur noch einen pfeil
und dieser teil
ja ist sowie ein unendlicher fall und
ich musste mehrere sex mit ins ende
nehmen und da sind pfeil und bogen
wirklich sehr sehr wichtig dann wurde
mir geschrieben luca schärfe muss
unbedingt auf dem schwert packen das
kann man kombinieren weil du ja gerade
nur schärfe 2 auf seinem schwert hast
dann kannst du safe zu schärfen 3 oder
chef hier machen schützen natürlich
selbstverstänlich auch in brust harnisch
und auf die diamant rose drauf also
danke danke danke für eure zahlreichen
tipps in den kommentaren ich kann jetzt
gar nicht alle kommentare hier
einblenden norbert dahinter splatter
movie hell ist ja eigentlich
sorry an alle die das video gerade bei
nacht gucken ich glaube die haben gerade
den augenlichts entzündung zum glück bin
ich kein arzt geworden meine mission für
das heutige video ist es auf jeden fall
und das tier wahrscheinlich auch schon
im titel und im klang schnell
eingeblendet meine lieben freunde dass
wir erstmal diesem bereich vorne
verlassen werden das komplette studium
und uns in richtung eines zweiten endes
bewegen was sich ja anscheinend dort
hinten irgendwo befinden wird die sache
ist dass wir schon in der vorletzten
episode im wasser dorf ban und ich dort
ein händler auge geschmissen habe und
dieses ende augen eine komplett andere
richtung gegangen ist als dass
stronghold sich das was nicht dort
befindet wo wir gerade waren teils jetzt
richtiges deutsch verfasste nicht
allerdings habe ich mir gedacht wenn ich
noch in dem stronghold in der letzten
episode habe ich da so viele verzauberte
bücher gefunden ich brauche noch mehr es
kann nicht schaden deswegen da ich eh
noch zwei ende augen hier am start habe
habe ich mir gedacht entdecken wir
bitten wir sie hoffentlich finden wir
das heute überhaupt eine zweite festung
ein zweites frommhold und werden dort
noch einige sachen mehr finden da vorne
seht ihr schon dass man so trauer insel
ich wollte diese überfahrt über den
ozean eigentlich nutzen und mich noch
über eine andere sache ganz kurz
informieren also das ist der plan für
die heutige episode und ihr seht schon
hinten los lukas eingeblendet denn bei
der liebe freunde ich bringen endlich
mal wieder nach dem ja bestimmt neues
merchandise rauskommt passend zur folge
100 in den luca - shop.de also tragt
euch fest in den kalender ein wenn folge
100 von minecraft luca kommt auch dieser
vintage zweiter heraus dort ist lukas
eingestickt zusammen mit einem insel
stieg und 20 21 weil da was soll das
hier
warum ist jetzt so ein ding
[Musik]
wir treiben immer irgendwelche endermann
ihr unwesen
hier steht allerdings auch noch anders
entscheidet schon schön hier
war ich schon sehr hin was ist alles
gebaut haben na ja meine lieben freunde
ich will hier gar nicht lange herumreden
das kommt auf jeden fall neues mädchen
das in den lukas shop.de einerseits der
vintage twitter in grün den ich gerade
schon gezeigt hatte den hatte ich die
tage tatsächlich auch in einer instagram
story an wo ja wir irgend so hafen in
hamburg waren und den sweater hatte ich
ebenfalls bereits in den letzten
episoden minecraft mit luca hier
angesagt ist allerdings dass ich da
irgendwie nicht so richtig darauf
eingegangen bin von der jetzt für euch
ganz gut sehen vor dass dieser vintage
herauskommen wird feiere ich sehr sehr
sehr sehr dollar und was auch noch
rauskommen wird ist dieser blaue hoodie
da steht wieder einen drauf da ist meine
kleine los luxusinsel mainz miley das
schaf ist drauf und wir haben so einen
richtig geilen druck also das ist die
vision 3d druck oder so feiere ich auch
sehr sehr krass ist ein hund die
rückseite kann ich euch jetzt noch nicht
zeigen auf der rückseite steht erst
drauf und das ist auch der grund warum
diese ganzen produkte erst passen
zufolge 100 rauskommen werden in den
lukas shop denn passend zur folge 100
kommt ja auch der speed raus ich sage
jetzt die ganzen bücher allerdings erst
mal hier in meinen kisten denn meine
lieben freunde wie vorhin bereits gesagt
möchte ich in der heutigen episode nicht
die ganzen sachen schon verzaubern da
bin ich immer noch so ein bisschen
unsicher nicht dass ich irgendwas doch
falsch vertraute also wenn ihr tipps
abschrecken und in die kommentare denn
ich möchte ja wie bereits auch gesagt
heute schon im video mich heute noch mal
in richtung
wasser dorf bewegen um zu schauen ob ich
dort eventuell noch ein zweites
stronghold finden werde und darauf
bereite ich mich jetzt erst mal ganz
kurz vor was ich auf jeden fall nicht
vergessen darf ist ein bettchen denn man
weiß natürlich nie wie lange der weg
sein wir zum zweiten strong holz kann
sein dass ich deutlich länger unterwegs
sein werde als das bei der bei dem
ersten formel der fall war die sache ist
allerdings dass sich hier unten ja auch
direkt noch einige brötchen stehen habe
mit denen ich mich direkt wieder in
richtung wasser drauf bewegen kann von
euch denn ganz gute time letztlich zum
wasser dorthin fahre und wahrscheinlich
auch wie ich eine runde kurz gleich
schlafen gehen muss denn die sonne geht
jeden moment wieder unter
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder hier hinten in
unserem dörfchen angekommen habt mich
vermisst
denn sonst
will ich ja hier gibt es tatsächlich
auch gar nicht mehr so viel zu sehen das
ist das kleinste dorf was ich glaub ich
jeden minecraft generell entdeckte aber
hier und diese zeit für dich da
eingesetzt habe hinten haben wir den
ganzen sand sogar abgebaut fällt mir auf
die sache ist dass wir gar nicht lange
zeit verlieren brauchen
[Musik]
ich bin immer idiot
ich habe dieses ende augen nicht hier
geworfen sondern im wasser dorf
aber ich war während der tat am handy
und ein paar nachrichten gelesen und
ja
wir können es ja hier auch einfach mal
testen ich möchte einfach mal ändert
härle hoch die frage seit
[Musik]
wir können erst mal in diese richtung
hinten laufen die sache ist ich habe
jetzt gerade halt nur zwei ende appellen
ich bin auch selbst schuld dass ich
nicht noch mehr blaze trotz mitgenommen
habe oder so die sache ist allerdings
dass ich jetzt einfach mal auf mein
gefühl vertrauen jetzt erstmal
ordentliches stück in die richtung hier
laufe es macht zwar überhaupt keinen
sinn dass ich das jetzt hier mache weil
ich deutlich zu weit weg bin von mir zu
hause aber vielleicht ist dass
stronghold was in die richtung zeigt er
dann schlussendlich genau das gleiche
stronghold was wir hinten im wasser dorf
auch insekten von daher positiv sehen
stronghold gibt es auch nicht so häufig
es wird wahrscheinlich genau das gleiche
sein deswegen ist es ja auch egal als
besetzt und für mich nur doof dass ich
gerade so lange unterwegs war mit der
überwasser card weg dauert wirklich
immer dann bin ich gut gefahren
viereinhalb minuten aber das läuft schon
alles ich bin guten mutes dass wir alles
vernünftig getrieben von ajax ihn wir
hier erst mal fix den berg hoch und
ihnen auf der anderen seite hätte auch
wieder runter ich werde gleich wenn wir
da vorne auf der freien fläche sind
einfach mal das zweite ende
augenschmerzen so dass wir vielleicht
schon ein bisschen genauer wissen wo wir
genau hin müssen da wurden übrigens auch
und in die kommentare geschrieben das
ist nicht heiß wenn sein ende august
platz dass dort dann das dorf ist bzw
stronghold ist nicht das dorf ich glaub
ich habe darauf gesagt weil ich da
hinten drauf gesehen habe oder acht neue
spieler so heiß
sondern das ist nur dass stronghold wenn
das ende august 60 nach unten geht und
das ist hier leider nicht der fall
perfekte gab
man mir so eine scheiße passiert er wir
müssen also auf jeden fall noch mal ins
wasser und dementsprechend hier noch mal
so ein bisschen weiter fahren an diesen
komischen sachen hier vorbei da wurde
mir auch mal irgendwann geschrieben dass
die teile richtig wertvoll sind dass man
mit denen richtig gut handeln kann mit
irgendwelchen billiger ich glaube
allerdings dass wir das alles gar nicht
mehr brauchen wir am 37 level wir
befinden uns gerade in folge 92 folge 99
wird mehr special eigentlich als folge
100 denn ich habe mir während eines
überlegten für folge 99 werdet ihr dann
allerdings sehen generell die letzten
beiden folgen werden extrem geil wir
kommen hier vorne das verstehe ich nicht
von einem kompletten icex bioware über
eine wüste also das macht gar keinen
sinn ihren mann geschafft dann werde ich
auf jeden fall gleich nochmal ende auge
werfen wenn wir hier auf dem festland
angekommen sind die sache ist dass es
eine 20-prozentige chance gibt ich habe
ich ein bisschen informiert es gibt eine
20 prozentige chance dass ein ende
august geht wenn man es wird das heißt
dadurch dass sich zwei ende augen habe
wird es so sein dies ist nur eine hülle
es wird auf jeden fall so sein dass ich
beide maximal 10
[Musik]
ich habe eine idee
ich könnte
zu diesem ding hingehen die angreifen
dann zurück zum wüsten dorf fahren dass
ein überfall kommen so dass ich noch ein
nächstes totem der unsterblichkeit
bekomme weil
wenn ich im ende sterbe ist das totem
der und sterblichkeit von um endlich
wichtiger bedeutung die sache ist
allerdings dass unser ziel ja eigentlich
dass stronghold ist und heute werden wir
auf keinen fall beides hinkriegen da
hinten sind riesige berge ich feier
dieses savannen bio auch einfach extrem
da oben machen ja das ist nun
ein baum der sich aufgebaut hat ich
dachte das wäre auch wieder so ein
komisches portal was wir auch hinten dem
schnee bedeckt haben die sache ist
allerdings dass ich erst mal gerne
wissen möchte wo dass stronghold ist
bevor ich mich jetzt dahin mehr deswegen
nehme ich noch mal eine ende augen und
schmeißt die hoch ich brauche
tatsächlich für unten kein einziges ende
auge denn ich will ja auch nicht das
okay das haben wir auf jeden fall wieder
ich will ja auch nicht in das ende über
das portal dort gehen da ist es nicht
darum ich will ja auch nicht in dem in
der festung dann ins ende gehen und das
ein vorteil vernünftig bestücken mit den
ende augen sondern ich will einfach nur
runter und mir ein paar verzauberungen
holen ich will mich auch gar nicht
irgendwie da unten auf er zu
konzentrieren oder auf diamanten die man
vielleicht findet oder keine ahnung was
die sache ist dass ich wirklich nur die
verzauberung haben möchte und am
liebsten halt am liebsten halt irgendwie
nochmal schärfe fünfter finde oder
schutz 5 oder irgendwie sowas dass sich
halt um so besser vorbereitet bin
immer noch nicht
wie weit muss ich dennoch laufen ich bin
jetzt hier vorne einfach mal den berg
hoch geklettert da unten habe ich ja
gerade das ende auge geworfen deswegen
schmeiße ich von hier oben jetzt auch
noch mal eins
[Musik]
ich meine ich bin schon happy genug dass
die teile überhaupt erstmal nicht kaputt
gespart das gleiche ende auge gleich zum
siebten mal oder so die chance ist wie
gesagt 20 prozent dass das teil kaputt
geht allerdings will ich das teil jetzt
langsam mal finden und ich will auch
eigentlich erster stronghold gehen und
danach die da vorne besiegen bei diesem
komischen tower damit ich danach zum
wüsten dorf gehen kann dann habe ich
nämlich noch mal ein bisschen action
hier zum ende des projekts plus können
uns ein totem meer und sterblichkeit
noch hohn und hoffentlich weil wir das
schon heute überhaupt sind mit meinen
zwei ende augen hier dann noch mal ein
bisschen verzauberungen holen sofern es
dort unten denn auch bücher gibt die
sonne geht da hinten schon unter ich bin
dieses savannen bio wirklich extrem
schön aber ihr wisst ja glaube ich dass
ich jedes spiel minecraft mannschaft das
generell so ein extrem geiles spiel geht
es jetzt kaputt
es geht kaputt
heißt das jetzt wir sind jetzt hier
richtig oder ich hab ich erst mal ganz
kurz schlafen also hier fordern wir
gerade geschlafen und das ende auge was
wir hier geworfen haben und das was wir
hier geworfen haben die ihn immer in
diese richtung von daher würde ich sagen
laufen jetzt einfach noch mal ein
bisschen hin und ich laufe jetzt
wirklich auch mal ein bisschen länger
denn ich will nicht dass ich jetzt ein
ende august und das ist irgendwie direkt
wieder kaputt geht wir müssen auf jeden
fall einmal diese animation haben dass
das ende auge in den boden rein geht das
wäre wirklich sehr sehr wild aber ich
weiß auch gar nicht warum ich dann so
ein krasses glück hatte dass beim ersten
sturm heute als das ende august gegangen
ist halt wirklich einfach das ding
dort war wo das eine auge einfach
tatsächlich da nur kaputt gegangen ist
also ich dachte das wäre die animation
dass das heißt hey guck mal ich geh
kaputt das heißt hier ist das ende
wusste gleich dass die teile kaputt
gehen können durch ganz normale werfen
aber gut meine lieben freunde ich würde
sagen im moment herz kam ich schmeiße
mein ende auge und wir schauen mal wo es
hingeht das geht noch da vorne und geht
es kaputt ich hoffe
[Musik]
ich war's ein dicker
es ist auf jeden fall weiterhin in diese
richtung gegangen das heißt wir müssen
jetzt einfach spekulieren wir müssen
gucken ob wir gleich vielleicht irgendwo
in höhlen eingang ist oder irgendwie
sowas dass wir uns hier runter bauen
können aber ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht wie weit ich hier noch laufen
solche vorne sieht auf jeden fall aus
als wird eine höhle runter gehen
allerdings nicht oder ist das hier vorne
vielleicht den höhleneingang nicht das
ist doch
[Musik]
das kann eigentlich nur ein gutes
zeichen sein
ich sehe hier was anders geht auf jeden
fall runter also wenn hier unten
wenn hier unten dass stronghold sein
sollte dann bin ich wirklich minecraft
profi schlechthin dann schreibt einfach
in die kommentare
der profi liga
ich glaube die ganze linke nur nach oben
nicht richtig an
[Musik]
dass ich idiot bin ich einfach mehr ende
augen mitgenommen habe provinz ist soll
man hier auf der anderen seite vom
wasser und gehen hier auch nochmal kurz
runter das kann doch nicht sein dass ich
jetzt
irgendwo hier muss es sein
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass ich
noch viel weiter laufen muss die vorne
kamen wir auf jeden fall rein gerade in
die höhle schauen aus wie eventuell noch
im zweiten höhleneingang gibt es sieht
allerdings wirklich leider nicht danach
aus ich weiß nicht was ich jetzt machen
soll ich weiß nicht ob wir noch weiter
in die richtung laufen müssen ob da noch
irgendwie
irgendwas zu sehen ist was den song hold
eingang gibt aber dass die sagen wir
wirklich schon sehr krass heraus mit dem
berg und so weiter und so fort reit-ag
später
ich gebe auf ich
habe verkackt
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen hier geht's
lang ich auch nicht lange das ist nur
ein kleiner see
muss man sich auch mal eingestehen
bisher war alles
[Musik]
ist das
also
das sind halt stein ziegeln
und diese stein ziegel
gibt es auch im stronghold als ich weiß
nicht ob das uns jetzt auf das
stronghold hin deuten möchte ob das
zeigt hey guck mal bei sich in der nähe
runter weil wir unsere anderen festungen
der in der letzten episode noch waren
war es auch der fall dass genau an dem
ort wo das war schlussendlich dass
stronghold war es kann sein dass ich
mich dann ein bisschen verlaufen sind
die richtung gegangen bin ich kann es
mir allerdings sehr gut vorstellen dass
wir vielleicht hier
[Musik]
den eingang haben
oder rede ich mir dass gerade ein
reparatur und schuss sicher
brauchen wir nicht wir brauchen die
goldbarren auf jeden fall
und den christen die nicht mehr mit
[Musik]
aber soll ich mich jetzt hier runter
bauen in gold blog hier nehme ich auf
jeden fall noch mal ganz kurz mit wir
haben auf jeden fall auch ein schaf am
start und ich werde jetzt einfach mal
probieren das war ja in der
einen oder anderen festung war es ja
auch so dass nicht dort neben mich
einfach runter gebaut haben und dann war
dort der stronghold also das wäre jetzt
ein krasser zufall glauben
[Musik]
wir sind schon wieder nicht
wisst ihr was ich jetzt einfach nur noch
machen werde ich setze jetzt mein
brötchen hier hinfahren
[Musik]
was hätten wir denn hier heute alles auf
der einen seite denke ich mir gerade so
man irgendwie habe ich gar nicht lust
diese episode hier hochzuladen weil ich
wieder wie der größte idiot wirke ich
gehe mit zwei ende augen los um
stronghold zu finden wie so ein
vollidiot der anderen seite denke ich
mir das ist irgendwie auch geil weil
guckt euch das mal an
ohne irgendeine modifikation hat
minecraft das hier erschaffen
das sieht ja todes heftig aus die sache
ist allerdings und das wollte ich gerade
auch sagen dass mein einziges ziel für
die heutige episode nun nur noch sein
wird dass ich zu diesem komischen tower
da zurückfinde der bei auf jeden fall
ein stückchen in die richtung da hinten
und dass ich dann dort auf jeden fall
ein bisschen stress machen werde so dass
die leute also diese verbrecher oder wie
die den namen vergessen
einbrecher überfall menschen auf jeden
fall dass die mich ein bisschen hassen
und dann werde ich in der nächsten
episode zurück zum wüsten dorf gehen und
dort einen überfall anzetteln lassen so
dass ich mir dort hoffentlich ein
zweites der unsterblichkeit holen kann
[Musik]
einfach ein esel
so stark
der kanadisch
nun stimmt das ist einfach folge 290
hinweg immer noch neue sachen ihren
minecraft ich will auch gar nicht wissen
wie es in staffel 2 dann sein wird wenn
wir auch eine komplett neue minecraft
version spielen wer so ein 1.17 ist
herausgekommen extrem krasse neue höhlen
warten auf uns neue monster neue
friedliche tiere also es wird
geisteskrank ich freue mich extrem auf
staffel 2 wann auch immer sie starten
wird schauen wir mal ob das erst im
winter seien wir doch schon im herbst da
hinten sehen wir allerdings schon am
horizont den
außenposten heißt es ja glaube ich und
wir sehen auch links beziehungsweise
nehmen das auch schon anhand der
sinkenden helligkeit hier war dass die
sonne untergeht deswegen meine lieben
freunde ich schlage vor dem turm ganz
fix bei eben kurz mein kleines wäldchen
hier auf beziehungsweise die sonne habe
ich noch nicht soweit untergegangen dass
wir direkt schon schlafen gehen können
wir können uns einfach mal hier direkt
neben die lava legen damit wir endlich
zumindest ein bisschen warm haben
allerdings ist mein plan ist wie bereits
gesagt erst mal nur noch dass ich den
überfall so ein bisschen ein leute dass
ich davor übergehen so dass ich oben
diese verzauberung bekomme überfall oder
irgendwie so da heißt es so
ich weiß nicht ob ich die ganze zeit
schluss klar was ich wohne allerdings
auch sagen noch sagen wollte war das
irgendwie diese folge ein bisschen
kummer bereitet weil ich mir denke nicht
so richtig geklappt auf der andern seite
denke ich mir aber auch eigentlich ganz
geile episode weil wir halt geile sachen
entdeckt haben und wir waren zwar immer
viel unterwegs in minecraft mit luca wir
haben auch eine menge immer entdeckt
allerdings heute doch noch mal ein
bisschen mehr ihr seht auch schon nicht
einfach die ganzen anderen gar nicht
mehr denn ihr wisst schon oben rechts
eingeblendet ich habe das symbol
erreicht und das reicht damit ich damit
in dorf gehen kann und
ja dass diese ganzen leute mich danach
folgen und orten überfall stattfindet
hier oben drin ist immer nur scheiße
weiß und irgendwie sowas kommt die info
blätter zählen wir meine lieben freunde
laufen jetzt mal ganz kurz prämiert
jährlich um 1 ganzen hier viele
ich noch mal kurz ein bisschen neben
abholen konnten starkem eine rüstung ist
es natürlich hier stehen so viele von
denen gerade
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie viele das
eine rüstung gelobt und jetzt die bilder
parat oder was
ja
meine lieben freunde und ich hoffe euch
hat die heutige episode minecraft luca
gefallen wenn es das getan hat dann lass
gern einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da moniert meinen kanal und klickt
auf die glocke wenn ihr neue videos
nicht verpassen wollt ich weiß gerade
gar nicht ob ich richtig laufe ich glaub
ich muss in diese richtung wir haben ja
recht am horizont gesehen sie verfolgen
mich hier immer noch teilweise wir
bewegen uns auf jeden fall in der
nächsten episode zurück zum wüsten dorf
zetteln dort dementsprechend einen
überfall an und werden diesen
hoffentlich gewinnen so dass wir ein
weiteres totem der unsterblichkeit
bekommen sonst müssen wir halt leider
abbauen wieder zurück auf meine welt
verfolgen die immer noch ich glaube
nicht
[Musik]
daher bleibe ich jetzt einfach mal hier
stehen meine lieben freunde und wir
sehen uns dann in der nächsten episode
wieder wird ich weiß ja was übermorgen
kommen wird oder in vier tagen schauen
wir mal
ihnen gehört ganz viel geredet aber ganz
wenig gesagt
[Musik]